we have this report from timcast.com
Trump vows to appoint special prosecutor
to go after Biden if elected saying now
that the seal is broken in addition to
closing the border and removing all of
the criminal elements that have
illegally invaded our country making
America energy independent and even
dominant again and immediately ending
the war between Russia and Ukraine I
will appoint a real special prosecutor
to go out for the most corrupt president
in the history of the U.S Joe Biden the
entire Biden crime family and all others
involved with the destruction of our
elections borders and Country itself
election interference at a level never
seen before in our country in a
subsequent post so now that we know that
Trump is being charged and the seal has
been broken as you said in more ways
than one seal has been broken well
that's it yeah there there's there's no
way out of it now the next time a
republican gets elected it's going to be
political lawfare 100 percent
and it has to be because you know when
he he kind of campaigned on this whole
Locker up we're going to go after
Hillary Clinton and then I think he got
elected and he went for this thing like
let's be compassionate let's unite the
country let's bring people together and
it was a huge mistake I mean look
exactly what they're doing yeah I don't
think I'll make that yeah that's a bad
mistake will be made again
yeah Jack
uh getting a report now from post my
guys opposed Millennial they are saying
the sites are back up they've got all
the information from the bombshell story
that resulted in a DDOS attack
post-millennial human event make sure
you go subscribe by the way to make sure
that we can fend off the next great
opportunity for a plug by the way all
right but yeah we pull up post
millennial quite a bit on the show and
we have Libyan quite a bit so what
happened is before the show I'm like you
know let's see what the post millennial
is not about and it wasn't working and
then Jack's like well we just put out
these big stories and sure enough but uh
back to uh Donald Trump I thought it was
a resting point and yeah no it was too
big too big but uh Trump's gonna go
after Joe Biden so obviously you know
Brandon and I are in agreement Jack I'm
curious what you think
it's going too far
you know it's it's really gone too far
at this point where you've got a
situation where this this and keep in
mind that it's it's not just if you
think it's just Joe Biden and Hunter
Biden that are taking foreign money in
the United States government you've got
you if you want to be serious about this
and I would say as a way to take this
out of the necessary necessarily like
Left Right dichotomy of it uh you know
Republicans are going to Or democrats
are going to Republican so so Biden and
all his guys are going after Trump and
they're saying oh you didn't you know
classify you didn't you didn't say it
was Declassified even though he's the
president he has declassification
ability they're going after him for all
this stuff uh that we already know that
Hillary got away with
to take it out of that I would say that
you don't just need the special
prosecutor for Biden I do that obviously
because we've got way too much
information now plus by the way it
apparently there was an investigation
that for whatever reason this level the
highest levels of the FBI are protecting
the bidens even though we know that they
already have this information they had
the information when President Trump was
asking about it they wouldn't give it to
him he goes and asks uh Ukraine about it
because he's like well if I can't get it
from my side I'm going to ask the other
side because he's a problem solver right
you know he's a pragmatic guy
um businessman that we need an entire
commission I think we need a federal
commission about foreign money that's
going in this is something where look if
you are a Bernie Sanders supporter or I
guess these days you would say an RFK
supporter and you're actually concerned
about money and politics wouldn't it be
a massive issue if there were foreign
oligarchs and foreign funds that were
paying into our politics and shouldn't
we know about that and it's probably
worse than just that I mean I'd imagine
the Chinese Communist party is
heavily investing in there you go
political candidates and they can do it
through very special ways they can give
money to a corporation that does as
mentioned you're mentioning mentioning
earlier Dianne Feinstein turned this
into a cottage industry for her and her
husband it's it's not so easy to prove
these things a company that that sells
Sombreros in China sends two million
dollars to a company that you know makes
a specific fiber they use and they say
here's what we do we have that company
double its order so it looks totally
normal then that company there's The
fibering Hires a few Consultants at a
couple hundred thousand dollars who then
hire this plumber and so it all looks
legitimate and how do you know which one
was the bribe they do these things in
Chicago all the time hey you know that
contract that's coming up
get get us that contract for you know
this amount of money and then I'll have
I'll talk to my brother and we'll make
sure that he buys from you next time and
then that's that's Kickbacks that's how
it all works so China can say we're
gonna buy X product from your company so
long as X amounts of those dollars go to
this political action committee through
you because we can't legally do it and
no one will be able to prove it well or
or just looking at the Feinstein
situation so
um Senator Feinstein in California was
one so she's she's green energy right
she's she's climate change we have to
protect the environment what did she do
she used legislation and she championed
legislation in this country to prevent
the development of rare Earth elements
within the United States that we are not
going to go after those we are going to
protect them we're going to leave this
this sacred land exactly the way it is
exactly whereas meanwhile what's her
husband doing her husband is being given
deals in China with the exact same
companies that are going after Rare
Earth elements and then purchasing those
resource sources and the mineral rights
all around the world for China how did
they Corner the market they cornered the
Senators first yep
man I oh we're gonna say I was gonna say
Trump's got arrest all of them this is
my feeling about what Trump's saying he
he's like when I get back into office
I'm gonna arrest them I'm gonna set
things right and what it feels like is a
story of like he came in the first time
he's like all these poisonous snakes I'm
gonna kill all these snakes and and make
it snake and we'll be like we're like
okay good less poisonous snakes he went
in he didn't destroy the snakes and then
he got bit by one and now he's poisoned
and he's like when I get back in I'm
gonna kill all the snakes and you're
like dude relax rest you've been
poisoned like they're already hitting
him with like 70 plus federal felony
charges like dude you're in no position
to run for president because they're
terrified of him I know there's really
in the position I mean he's a position
where they can take him off the ballot
if he's being there's a reason that
nobody else is being targeted like this
I mean I I think that the this the Trump
movement singularly represents the most
viable
anti-establishment movement in this
country and because it became so it
attained critical mass that's the reason
you're seeing this
pathogen-like response to it by the
system that you're seeing you'll see
Republicans and Democrats will link arms
the bushes and the clintons and the
Obamas to go after Trump because they
know that he's the one person that
actually represents a threat to them on
a much grander scale and by the way if
he wasn't leading in all the polls and
but CBS yugub has him up what 38 points
or something right now it's not exactly
like a pro-trump poll
um he's leading Biden in many national
polls I think if he wasn't leading you
wouldn't see these charges you wouldn't
see anything about him that that would
fit more the hey let's let this guy go
you know out to pasture kind of model
but we think he's too damaged well I
think not psychologically mentally
anything like that just he's in a in a
legal state right now where he's gonna
have a hard time getting his name on a
ballot like he if they but that's the
point yeah exactly so what do you mean
get his name on the ballot if he well
from what I understand if he's indicted
for federal charges and then found
guilty on any of them they
is that not right well some people are
saying that the indictment States will
make moves to remove his name from the
ballot he can still run he can still be
elected he can pardon himself I don't
know if it's true but people have
chatted to us saying that so
there's two pieces to this
um one is that so the only thing that
can prevent you from being president is
an impeachment like like fully prevent
you from being president is impeachment
it's the only thing you mean conviction
right impeachment and conviction
impeachment and conviction yes a a fully
carried through conviction and
impeachment which has never happened by
the way in U.S history
um that then the other piece of it which
I think is this sort of loophole that
they tried to do this with Margaret
Taylor green and they were attempting to
do with Madison cawthorne done in North
Carolina was this these Civil War era
laws that are on the books in some of
the states that say if you were a member
of an Insurrection that you can no
longer hold office in the United States
and that these laws do apply in these
states they were written obviously for
Confederates
um to say that okay if you had been some
official in the Confederacy now George
has been admitted you know back to the
Union Mississippi et cetera Alabama that
you can't go and run for office us again
because you were part of that so what
they're trying to do is apply that so if
and and I believe they will by the way
like this this indictment tomorrow on
Trump
um is not going to be the only one they
are going to continue on with the
indictment in Georgia over you know find
the votes which you know it was like
just Trump talking a phone call and then
I do believe that they're going to go
after and and bran obviously you've got
more information on this they're going
to take
those proud boy and oath keeper
indictments for seditious conspiracy and
their gun and Julie Kelly's talked about
this as well so you know I'm not going
to say like this isn't 100 my idea that
they're gonna just switch the names for
president Trump because that then and by
the way in a DC District would trigger
those laws in those States and set up a
I mean we're obviously not charted
territory like massive Uncharted
Territory here in terms of all of these
things but it would set up a huge legal
challenge for him now when they did this
with Marjorie Taylor green the judge
basically ruled for her 100 but Marjorie
Taylor green had never been indicted and
convicted of anything that would be
considered an Insurrection in fact up
until this conspiracy case no one had
been charged with anything that would be
considered even close to that and so the
idea being is that is there a
possibility I mean there it's it's some
like insane figment of a blue Anon type
Duran conspiracy but that's literally
how far they're willing to go to try to
stop Trump there's um there's a smaller
story besides proud boys and Oath
Keepers that's already happened that a
lot of people don't know about because
there's not enough reporting on January
6 but uh there's a j6 sir named Coy
Griffin uh he was a city councilman and
yes right in New Mexico and
um he got a misdemeanor charge didn't go
inside the capitol on January 6 and I
really want people to pay attention to
this so if you're watching and listening
look it up and share it
um but he was a city councilman in New
Mexico got a misdemeanor charge for
standing outside the capitol didn't go
inside the building uh but the Democrats
in New Mexico went after him to have
them removed from office for this very
reason and the judge went for it and he
was actually removed from his position
for being involved in Insurrection and
so he's now having to appeal that but
the point is that the president has
already been set we have re we have now
removed somebody from office for
Insurrection connected to January 6th so
that's we have precedent for that now
and of course they're going to do that
to Donald Trump I think you're exactly
right I think I think this is what it's
so you know people look at some of these
j6 cases and they'll say okay this is a
one-off this is one of no no they're
building towards this they're building
towards the person the precedent and
they're set they're moving slowly and
slowly and slowly to get to the point
where and by the way this case down in
Miami they know this is a weak case plus
they also know that because of the
district the jury pulled down there
which is an area that almost went for
Trump in 20 that decisively went for um
DeSantis in 22. I mean there you try and
tell me that you're not going to pull 12
people and not at least get a couple of
like based Cuban you know Miami Cuban
guys on there that are like look we we
saw this in communist Cube but we know
exactly what you're doing we're not
going to go along with this you'll see
jury nullification you'll definitely get
a chance of that in DC you never will
not if your name is Donald Trump and
this is the big this is the Big
Challenge the the jurisdictions are
everything the the political and culture
bifurcation in this country is so near
absolute that if
you could have any liberal District just
be like Melinda item they can detect you
for anything they some random liberal
District in Washington can indict anyone
and then just you can get a ham sandwich
and then the people in that district
will convict because they don't care
about any kind of constitution Community
or laws they will just say now you're
guilty so that's why we talk about Trump
and these indictments I'm asking people
do you really think a New York jury is
going to acquit Donald Trump you really
think a DC jury will equip that well
he's going to be in Miami so that's a
maybe for sure right Miami I would say
you he's got a 50 50 chance probably
even stronger than that because there's
no keep in mind that Miami even though
that's where the court is the district
itself is actually bigger than just
Miami-Dade County right uh the the
southern district of Florida so you've
got I mean remember we how many people
move down because of kovid Etc we all
know the story right and the trending of
Latinos and the legalized Venezuelans
that have gone there the Cuban so I I
think he stands a pretty strong Fighting
Chance in that area just based on the
jury pool demographics but look at the
the rape civil trial in New York you had
a guy on that jury who even said he had
seen a few episodes of Tim cast still
saying that Donald Trump is responsible
for raping that woman in the most insane
story we've ever heard
so you look at New York and I'm like bro
they're gonna they're gonna convict them
and they're gonna and the judge is going
to say jail time I don't see a scenario
where a judge is like well now hold on
Donald Trump's a good guy so we're not
gonna they're gonna be like lock them up
New York is is a very bad uh uh venue
for Donald Trump but it's not as bad as
DC I don't think and he's actually more
popular in New York than people think
than people I mean it's overwhelmingly
people are against him there but he he's
more popular than people think in New
York no I don't I don't see so first
what will happen is the jurors
identities will get leaked and then the
judge will probably be like who cares
something like that will happen then
you're going to hear story like no juror
who is entering the the courthouse to
pass judgment on Donald Trump to issue a
verdict is going to
whether they like Trump or not I just
don't see it happening the reason that
one guy probably said yeah you know what
Trump is responsible for this is because
they probably said to him listen they're
probably sitting in the in the in the
jury deliberation or whatever room it's
called
and they said I don't know or care about
Donald Trump I don't want Auntie for
throwing bricks at my window exactly
you're guilty yep well that's uh that's
a tampered jury you need it look yeah
how would we expect to have an impartial
trial in this situation because this is
this is the case that that happens when
you have a country that's been so
bifurcated the way we have where our
access to information has totally
changed because of the internet where
and and the rise of cable news that
you've set up a case now where there is
one part so conservatives generally will
say well you know I want to hear the
other side I want to call that we want
to we want to keep everyone on the same
standard we want to make sure that you
know everyone's playing by the rules
where's the left the left will just sit
there and say I want to destroy the
right I want to destroy anyone who's
related Donald Trump who's related
January 6. um you see case after case
after case that's why they're putting a
Bannon on trial in New York right it
wasn't even in New York on trial in New
York that's why Ben he's got his four
month sentence that might be coming up
soon by the way that's that's already
happened for abandoned that he may have
to serve four months and it's looking
that way
um but you also had to to Brandon's
point there was a case where on that in
that very same so Steve was
uh raising money for this we build the
wall uh Endeavor where it was like this
private building the wall thing and one
of the guys so one of the guys took a a
plea deal uh Steve got pardoned and
there was another guy who actually went
to trials this is the federal case not
the state case there was another guy who
went trial in New York on this and there
was one juror who sat there the entire
time and said you know what you guys are
a bunch of liberals you guys are just
repeating whatever the government tells
you and you can even see in the like
Politico has the report the man repeated
anti-government conspiracy theories and
through the entire trial and refused to
go along with anything the other people
said so some somebody I think his name
was Roberto uh that someone actually did
get in like a normal person got onto one
of the trials and stood up to these guys
and stood up yeah or something so it was
a hung jury but that being said not
exactly a great legal strategy if you're
if you're hoping for that but the media
also has got gotten very involved in the
justice system and and I think that
there I wouldn't be surprised if they're
bullying jurors and stuff as well I mean
throughout my j6 criminal case
um I had reporters from CNN contacting
my prosecutors asking them to rethink
giving me a plea deal I'm literally just
inserting themselves into the system
MSNBC had a guy chasing the the Kyle
Rittenhouse jury remember the jury
threatened was going back and then they
lied about it they lied about that it
was happening and they and so MSNBC put
out the statement or and then NBC as
well because it was like he was an NBC
Stringer basically and they said oh we
don't have anyone doing that and then
they found the Purdue and then they
found the guy and said no here's the
producer this I I work for him because
he was you know he wanted to stay out of
jail basically yeah and a hundred
percent that's that's 100 what they do
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored member only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time